who are you looking at nobody I just
really like skateboards since when
rhyme we know you have a lot of
obstacles to overcome but stay strong we
can't wait to see what happens in season
5 up chicken girls and who is that cute
guy you're crushing on in the season 5
trailer we can't wait to find out
just don't let all the drama I get in
the way of your dreams and don't forget
who your true friends are Bratz chicken
girls is entering into its fifth season
fans are so excited but until the new
episodes come out we're going to dig
into the cast and find out their real
ages and relationships watch until the
end to find out who any leblanc
is dating here are the season 5 cast
members real ages and two relationships
before we get started did you guys see
the way any LeBlanc's character rhyme
was crushing on that cute boy in the
season 5 trailer she looked just like
the heart eye emoji Brian and her
friends the chicken girls have been
dancing together forever but now it's
getting real with high school life with
all the boy trouble and mean girl drama
they are going to have to work hard to
stay true to themselves and stay
together we are obsessed with the show
so if we want to get to know the actors
of season 5 a little better here's what
we know so far
birdie birdies played by the fabulous
Madison Lewis it's hard having to put on
a brave face all the time
Madison was born on December 24th 2002
which makes her 16 years old she is
currently dating Charles get neck
however she used to date Caden conrick
Tim the actor who plays Tim and chicken
girls goes by the name Caden con reek in
real life I'm Tim sharp you know
Kayla's much older cooler cousin he was
born on June 11 2001 that makes him 18
years old that's old enough to vote
Caden is single but he's to date Madison
Lewis Kayla Dylan can reek is 15 years
old she was born on April 13 2004 Dylan
is single but she used to go out with
Sebastian muy ace ace is played by
Carson looter
who was born on July 26th 2001 he just
turned 18 the summer and yes ladies he
is single le brick butler who plays the
role of le was a springtime baby
beautiful no matter what she were she
was born on March 8 2003 making her 16
years old she's also single for the
moments flash rush Butler aka flash was
born on September 4th 2004 which makes
him 15 years old
Raj's single as of right now but we
don't expect that to last very long Luna
alia Molden plays the part of Luna in
the show of course not she's a Leo born
August 14th 2001 this year she
celebrated a big birthday she just
officially turned 18 get in line guys
she is single
Drake Ju Ola who plays the role of Drake
is a Thanksgiving baby he was born on
November 23rd 2001 that's right he's a
thousand turn 18 years old in 2019 he is
currently dating Indiana Messara and
they look so happy together
Rooney Indiana Messara plays Rooney on
the show she's a little younger than her
boyfriend Jay at 17 years old
Indiana was born on August 23rd 2002
best vest is played by Aaron DeJohnette
who was born on February 16 2004 Aaron
is 15 years old and single TK Hayden
Summerall who plays the role of TK came
into this world on April 4 2005 he is 14
years old
Hayden is currently dating Tegan Murray
drew Arielle Martin or drew on the show
was born November 20 seconds 2000
drew is dating
cavalier and is 19 years old Monica the
role of Monica is played by Jenna Davis
I guess this is the MV arcade
she was born on May 5th 2004 which makes
her 15 years old and watch out fellas
this girl is single as of now Jade Colin
Silva who plays the role of Jade on the
series was born just a week away from
Halloween on October 23rd 2001 she will
be turning 18 and 2019 she isn't
currently dating anyone but that could
all change in the blink of an eye Quinn
the actress who plays Quinn
Riley Lewis is almost 17 she was born on
December 24 2002 and is currently dating
Tyler Phillips Robbie Matthew Soto or
Robbie on chicken girls was born on
April 19 2001 that makes him 18 years
old while Matthew is single there's a
rumor that he once dated Sophia dosey
Britney Lily cheese stars in the show as
Britney I think I would know more about
style than you she was born on September
19th 2003 Britney is 16 years old the
while Lily is single fans think she may
have dated a William Miller at some
point in time Beatrice Kaelin Slevin
born December 28th 2013 the series she
is almost 19 it appears that she is
single however there are unconfirmed
suspicions that Kailyn is dating Taylor
holder Kimmy
Kelsey beyond who plays Kimmy was born
on April 26th 2003 she is 16 years old
and single at this time harmony Hayley
LeBlanc who plays the role of harmony
was born on September 2nd 2008 of course
Hayley is too young for dating at just
11 years old she's focusing on playing
her character and juggling school at the
same time there will be plenty of time
for dating later in life Oh sweetie
when they heard I wanted the role no one
tried out rhyme rhyme is the star of the
show
she was played by Juliana LeBlanc or
Annie for short and he was born on
December 5th 2004 making her almost 15
years old she is currently dating Asher
angel who is your favorite character on
brats chicken girls tell us in the
comments give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]